eeuu cree que su cooperación en materia
de seguridad con mexico debe ser
actualizada con este objetivo el
secretario de estado- anthony blinken
encabeza este viernes una delegación
estadounidense ciudad de mexico las dos
naciones discutirán un nuevo plan
conocido como el marco del bicentenario
de eeuu y méxico para la seguridad la
salud pública y las comunidades seguras
el nuevo acuerdo sustituiría a la
iniciativa mérida que comenzó en 2007 y
con el que washington envió más de tres
mil millones de dólares a su vecino para
ayudarlo a luchar contra el narcotráfico
una contrariedad en cuanto a la
iniciativa mérida es una iniciativa que
ha estado en los libros durante creo que
ya son 13 años creemos que debemos
actualizar nuestra cooperación bilateral
en materia de seguridad y necesitamos un
enfoque que aborde las preocupaciones y
las prioridades de ambos gobiernos
pero méxico y advertió que busca que ese
programa de ayuda por lo menos con esa
perspectiva militar y a su fin tiene que
haber una nueva etapa
dejar atrás la iniciativa mérida que es
asistencialista está basada en otra
estrategia de seguridad totalmente
distinta a la que hoy se está
implementando el presidente lópez
obrador desde el inicio de su gobierno
prefirió que ese apoyo económico sirva
para impulsar programas sociales en el
salvador honduras y guatemala para batir
así la migración justamente el nuevo
acuerdo no prevé que méxico reciba
equipos o fondos militares sino que se
centre en la formación de personal y el
intercambio de información un encuentro
más que necesario según ambas naciones
en un momento en que la crisis
migratoria está en su punto más álgido